[Music]  jay-z's next video is a family affair  nobody wins when the family feels the  teaser for jay-z's latest visual family  feud dropped Thursday and it features a  couple of familiar faces  that's right Beyonce stars in the video  and even Blue Ivy makes an appearance  and clearly Queen B plans to bring all  the sleigh when it comes to her chic and  over-the-top looks for the visual the  family feels the video premieres  exclusively on tidal Friday and features  the couple in a confessional booth  fitting since the track off J's 444  album seemingly addresses Beyonce's  lemonade and themes of infidelity coiled  deep was the need to know are you  cheating cheating I am cheating on me  jay-z recently opened up to the New York  Times about cheating on Beyonce the  hardest thing is seeing pain on  someone's face that you caused and  didn't have to deal with yourself yeah  [Music]  you  [Music]